Vivek Bald: Our next presenter
is Elon Justice, whose thesis is
titled Hillbilly Talkback:
Co-Creation and
Counter-Narrative in Appalachia.
Kat Cizek, Eric, and I had have
had the honor and pleasure to
work with Elon. On her thesis
these last two years. Elon came
to CMS with a really inspiring
sense of clarity and purpose,
connected to her family roots in
Appalachia, her experiences in
media production and her
dedication to co creation as a,
an ethical mode of collective
self representation. Once she
started writing it, she made
things easy for Kat and me
because it just came, you know,
came forward, her writing just
beautifully written and
beautifully conceived. And I'm
just so excited to hear her
present and have her share this
work with all of you.
Thanks.
Elon Justice: I think you would
like me share my screen.
Alright. So like you've heard
the title of my thesis is
Hillbilly Talkback: Co-Creation
and Counter-Narrative in
Appalachia. So I'd quickly just
like to give an overview of what
I want to talk about today. So
I'll start out with my research
questions. And a little bit of
background on why I actually
chose this topic. I'm then going
into introducing the problem
itself, which is the way that
Appalachia is represented in
popular media. Next, I'll go
into a quick breakdown of four
common stereotypes of Appalachia
that exist in popular media
today. And then I want to shift
into a look at my own
documentary project called the
Appalachian Retelling Project,
and looking at how it approaches
co creation in order to create
new narratives of Appalachia.
And then just finish it off with
some conclusions. And some
lessons learned from all of
this. So my three research
questions. The first is what
images have historically been
used to represent Appalachia in
popular media, and what do these
images mean? The second is how
my co creative documentary
practices work to produce new
counter narratives of the
region. And the final one is
what sorts of narratives emerge
from these documentaries that
use co creative methodologies.
So I'll be breaking down this
presentation into two halves.
The first half will focus on
this first question of how
Appalachia is currently
portrayed in popular media. And
the second half will focus on a
case study of my own project
that's attempting to challenge
these representations. I did
want to take a second to explain
why I chose this topic, because
it's actually a pretty personal
topic for me. And it's something
whose effects I started noticing
at a really young age. So I grew
up in a town called Pikeville,
Kentucky, which you can see by
the green star on this map. I'm
located in far eastern Kentucky
close to both the West Virginia
and the Virginia borders. So
really in the heart of Central
Appalachia, which is the white
part on this map. And growing up
in the region, I think you tend
to become aware at a very young
age, that there's some sort of
difference between you and those
who live outside the mountains.
So I would notice it when my
parents and I went on vacation
that people might look at you
funny when they heard you talk
and they heard your accent. I
also remember watching TV, and I
would notice even as a kid that
Appalachia was pretty frequently
used either as the butt of a
joke, so maybe they would call
someone a hillbilly in order to
imply that they were dumb. And
other times I remember seeing it
portrayed as this object of
pity, just this place of utter
destitution, and helplessness.
And those were the only two
types of images that I ever saw
of my home. And neither of those
images captured the place that I
am. I'm so I'm going to talk
more about the broader effects
of this kind of representation
in a second. But there are a lot
of effects that I noticed from
this in my own life. I think
when you hear enough times that
you're not as smart or as
capable or as good as everyone
else, it's really hard to not
start believing it. So for
example, when I was 17, and I
started applying to colleges and
doing interviews, I remember
making this very conscious
effort to hide my accent,
because I didn't want the
interviewer to hear me say two
words and just decide that I was
Stupid. So I think that there's
this underlying sense that we're
less than or that were looked
down upon by others. And I think
that these sorts of effects tend
to trickle down and continue on
into new generations who feel
the same way. So I talked about
the effects that I noticed in my
own life. But as I began to do
more research on this topic, I
discovered that the effects were
actually much deeper and more
systemic than I had thought.
Appalachia has been portrayed in
popular media through a fairly
narrow set of images for over
100 years. And all of these
images add up to create this
sense that Appalachia is this
other space. Historian Anthony
Anthony Harkins actually
describes agile Appalachia as a
place that is in but not of
America. Often this is done by
the media spending what might be
considered a positive cultural
trait. So something like having
a tight knit family structure
into something negative, like
incest. I think doing so makes
it much easier for governments,
organizations, and just the
public at large to ignore the
problems that Appalachia faces.
And so issues like a higher than
average poverty rate, which is
exacerbated by things like
periodic flooding, lack of
broadband access, and inadequate
infrastructure, keeping people
trapped in the cycle of poverty,
as well as the region's opioid
epidemic continues to go
unsolved.
Because of the effects that I
just mentioned, and an overall
lack of job opportunity in
Appalachia, the region in the
last 10 years especially has
seen a large portion of its
population move out of the
region. This phenomenon has been
called a brain drain because
many of those who are left who
have left are young people at
the college degree or higher.
But on the other hand, those who
continue to live in the region
are far more likely to struggle
with and die from what's been
called diseases of despair,
including things like alcohol
abuse, prescription and illegal
drug overdose and suicide
compared to people who live
elsewhere. Another effect of the
way that Appalachia is
represented is that Appalachia
has become very acquainted with
whiteness. Although nearly 20%
of Appalachia population is non
white, and the area has become
increasingly diverse since 2010.
The region continues to be
portrayed almost entirely
through white people. And what's
interesting though, is that
author Meredith McCarroll
actually argues that popular
media often portrays Appalachian
people using the same tropes
that are used to represent
people, people of color. She
says this marks Appalachian
people as phenotypically white,
yet hierarchically non white,
and she turns this
categorization un-white. I do
want to emphasize here that by
this term, I'm not trying to say
that white Appalachian people
face the same legal or systemic
oppression faced by people of
color, or the Appalachians are
in effect, some sort of racial
minority. Instead, I mean, to
call attention to the way that
the subordination of a
phenotypically white Appalachia
to a normal America both upholds
and privileges some sort of true
whiteness, while simultaneously
erasing the existence of people
of color in Appalachia. And
finally, the way that Appalachia
is represented has effects on
the identity and self worth of
those who live there. These were
the effects that I noticed most
in my own life. One study
actually found that Appalachian
representation has caused many
in the region to form identities
based upon the US then
mentality, which prevents people
from uniting within and between
identity groups. Also, more
anecdotally, many Appalachian
people speak about feeling out
of place and institutions of
power, or just outside the
region in general, which is
something I have definitely
personally experienced during my
time at MIT. So I've discussed
the effects, but how can we be
sure that media representation
is actually one of the causes of
what's going on in Appalachia?
I'm framing my argument through
the work of Stuart Hall and
cultural studies, Hall writes,
the events have no meaning until
they're represented, whether
that's in language, visual
communication, or some other
type of representation. Because
of this representation is deeply
intertwined with questions of
power. Paul asks the question,
Who has the power in what
channels to circulate which
meanings to whom to call
attention to this relationship
between representation and
power, also writes that meaning
is a very fluid thing, and that
it can never be finally fixed.
However, certain meanings do
become privileged at different
points in time through systems
of ideology, which Hall defines
as the frameworks of thinking
and calculation about the world,
the ideas with which people
figure out how the social world
works, what their places in it,
and what they ought to do.
dominant ideologies are
perpetuated through
representation, and especially
media representation, because
it's the principal means through
which meanings are distributed
in our society today. Media
representation is especially
important in shaping how we
think about other groups of
people, because a lot of times
this is the only way that we
actually experienced these other
groups. Hall writes about the
way that difference is used as a
signifier in media and the
images of difference are often
read in broader terms of
cultural belonging. Generally,
the underlying message behind
these images is that those who
are some way different don't
So Next I'd like to just give a
brief breakdown of four common
belong
tropes that I've identified that
are used to portray Appalachia
in popular media. I've named
these degraded, violent,
placeless, and white. I broken
each of these image types down
into subcategories, which you
can see below the headings. And
in my thesis, I lay out the
history of each image type, but
for now, I will just leave it by
saying that each of these tropes
has a very long history and
representations of Appalachia.
So for example, images of
degraded Appalachia can actually
be traced back as far as the
1700s. And then off to the side,
I've given an example of either
a modern are a popular example
of each trope. So for degraded,
we've got Hillbilly Elegy, which
is a book that was a New York
Times bestseller in both 2016
and 2017. And was recently
turned to a film directed by Ron
Howard. For violence,
Deliverance, which has remained
a very popular and well known
film, despite being released
nearly 50 years ago. For place
lessness, The Beverly
Hillbillies, which was a hugely
popular sitcom in the 60s, and
I'm pretty sure still holds the
record for being the highest
rated rated half hour episode of
television in history. And for
whiteness, which I actually want
to explain that I chose this,
for lack of a better term,
because I'm trying to encompass
these three ideas of being white
male dominated, and this kind of
dangerous or extremist brand of
Christianity. But I chose The
Devil All the Time, which
actually came out on Netflix
last year, and it stars Tom
Holland, Bill Skarsgård, Robert
Pattinson, just this very well
known and popular cast. Well, I
don't have time to show an
example of all the images that I
talked about in my thesis, I did
want to play at least one clip
to give you an idea of the kinds
of images that I'm talking
about. So this is an ABC special
hosted by Diane Sawyer that
aired in 2009. I was in eighth
grade when a special came out.
And I think it had a bit big
impact on a lot of people my
age. And I'm going to play the
first two or so minutes and you
can see a lot of the imagery
that is very common in
representing Appalachia. Let me
know if you can't hear this.
TV Voiceover: Tonight on 2020,
Diane Sawyer special.
Singer: In the deep, dark hills
of eastern Kentucky
Diane Sawyer: Travel inside a
world apart.
Singer: That's the place where I
traced my bloodline
Diane Sawyer: To the creeks and
steep hollers of the oldest
mountains in America, home to
the descendants of pioneers,
driven by their dreams to call
through these dangerous passes
and create an American
continent. They are brave,
tough, wary of outsiders steeped
in family and faith.
They are also America's
legendary fighters.
Interviewee: On a portionate
basis, the Appalachian
population has lost more men and
women in America's wars than any
other part of the American
nation.
Diane Sawyer: So how is it so
many of these people have been
left behind? We take you tonight
to one of the poorest regions in
the nation, where men and women
die younger than other
Americans, where there's a
documented epidemic of drug
addiction, cancer,
toothlessness, alcoholism,
depression.
Singer: When the sun goes up
about ten in the morning and the
sun goes down
about three in the day
Elon Justice: Um, so now that
we've looked at some of the
common harmful ways that
Appalachia is represented in
media, I want to turn to the
second half of my research,
which focuses on how to create
new representations of
Appalachia that challenge these
old stereotypes. So first, I'd
quickly like to return to Stuart
Hall's work in representation.
Like I mentioned before, he
writes that the meaning of an
image can never be finally
fixed. And he uses the phrase
politics of the image to
describe this ongoing struggle
for any particular meaning to be
dominant. Because meaning can
never be finally fixed. This
opens up space to create counter
representations, which challenge
the current regime of
representation around a certain
topic or group. However, three
potential strategies to
challenge a dominant dominant
regime of representation, but
for the sake of time, I'll just
talk about the third one, which
he refers to as going inside the
image. This means that you
actually focus on the
stereotypes themselves that are
used to portray a group and you
try to complicate what that
stereotype means and how it came
to exist in the first place.
Hall says that this third
strategy is the most effective
not only at creating new images
of a group, but it's actually
challenging the way that they're
represented altogether. But in
addition to studying counter
narratives, I'm also really
interested in how co creation
and co creative documentary
specifically can work to produce
these counter narratives. To
give a sort of broad definition
of what co creation is. William
Uricchio and Kat Cizek define it
as an alternative to the single
authorship model that's common
in media production, and refers
to a constellation of frameworks
and production methods rather
than one specific methodology.
cocreation also allows projects
to emerge from within
communities and often involves a
wide variety of perspectives. It
requires deep listening on the
part of everyone involved. And
usually the final project isn't
defined at the outset, but
rather in excuse me, evolves out
of this process of listening and
discovery. Co-creation also seek
to challenge the power dynamics
that come with traditional modes
of media production, to Cizek
and Uricchio write that co
creation seeks to decolonize the
systems that oppressed and
stimulate projects that don't
simply document or passively
observe the world but insist on
change. So for these reasons, I
was really interested in seeing
how this type of methodology
that seeks to level power
imbalances could work to produce
new narratives of Appalachia
that would challenge the way
that it's currently represented.
Although in my thesis, I look at
two case studies of co-creative
documentaries set in Appalachia.
For the sake of time, I just
want to talk about one which is
my own project. I started the
Appalachian Retelling Project in
July of 2020. And it's a web
based participatory documentary
that aims to challenge
stereotypes of Appalachia
through collective storytelling.
So participants can submit
written video, photo, audio or
other content to me on nearly
any topic related to life in
Appalachia that I will then post
on the website, I provide
prompts online to get people to
think about stories from their
own lives, or the lives of their
family and community that might
act as a counter narrative of
Appalachia. And although these
prompts cover several different
subject areas, they all tie back
to a general theme, which is
what is the story about
Appalachia that you haven't seen
in mainstream media. I just
started off the project. And to
give people an idea of the types
of stories that I was looking
for, I recorded five short form
documentary videos that I
released on the website
throughout the last week of
July. Each video featured a
different Appalachian person who
spoke about a different topic
that was supposed to act as a
counter narrative. So I want to
show this video now, which is
actually a trailer that I made
for the project to try to get
more people to submit. But it
also features some clips from my
initial interviews, and also
some of the stories that were
submitted, just so you can get a
kind of general sense of the
project.
Unknown: I had a story I wanted
to tell.
Oh, yes, I want to tell a story
that defines what Appalachia is.
And I'd like to tell that
There's kind of this analogy
that I like to use. There's like
these two mountains. And one
mountain is the official
narrative. And this other
mountain you have is the
vernacular history is the oral
history. And in the middle, like
here in Appalachia, that's
that's where the hollers that
are the two mountains meet. And
that's also where you find the
most bio-diversity is in the
holler
if we want to paint Eastern
Kentucky, so it's like, whatever
the media does, you know,
uneducated or whatever kind of
people. I don't think that it's
I don't think that it's fair to
do that, because I think 99% of
people
are really, really great.
I have seen a lot in media, of
how Appalachia is portrayed, and
it's wrong. It's not what we
are. It's not
how we live,
telling the story of a white
male place filled with lazy
white males, impacts
policy.
It erases women it erases people
of color.
think it's important to
reimagine Appalachia, right?
We've had one narrative for a
long time. And honestly, it's
sort of like cheeps, the region
of all of its complexities,
right, all of the nuances like
like, we don't have to be just
one thing.
Interviewee: There's so many
people with amazing stories
about resilience and stories
about What the region does well
without romanticizing it,
without painting it as a place
that has given up. I think it
would paint a truer picture of
the region and a picture that
would
Unknown: actually help.
Elon Justice: So some aspects of
this project that we're co
creative, I'm actually dividing
my approach into two categories.
And the first is co creation
between myself as a media maker
with the Appalachian community.
And the second is co creation as
a member of the Appalachian
community myself, because I do
think that being Appalachian
affected how I approached this
project in ways that it might
not have if I had been from
somewhere else. So to summarize
my approach to co creation with
the community, I began asking
for feedback from people in the
community very early on as I
started this project, my
original idea was that the only
way to participate would be
through video. So kind of
continuing with the trend of the
original videos that I made. But
I got a lot of feedback that
most people wouldn't be
comfortable either with speaking
on camera, or doing these like
selfie style videos, or just
making their own videos in
general. So I started to adjust
my approach to allow people to
contribute in whichever way they
felt most comfortable. And I
eventually decided to just open
it up to basically any media
format. So including written
stories, photos, and videos. The
submissions process is
definitely the most
participatory aspect of this
project. I opened the project to
submissions the first week of
august 2020. And it's been open
ever since. So like I said,
people can submit in any media
format that they want. But they
can also speak about pretty much
any topic that they want, as
long as it's related to
Appalachia in some way. And it
doesn't violate our community
standards. I provide a list of
prompts on the website to get
people thinking about potential
topics to write about. So a
couple of examples are how have
you or someone you know, found
fulfillment in this region when
the media tells us that in order
to be successful, we have to
leave? And what's an example of
a portrayal of Appalachia and
media? They got it wrong, what
was wrong about it? And how
could it be better? These
questions are supposed to get
people to think about Appalachia
from the perspective of counter
narrative, and to directly speak
to exist existing stereotypes of
the region. However,
participants don't have to hold
to these questions. And I've
gotten submissions covering
everything from family histories
to like funny stories that have
been handed down between
generations. And I wouldn't say
that these sorts of stories
necessarily function as counter
narratives by themselves. But I
did decide to include them.
Because I think that just having
more media out there in the
world that's made by
Appalachians and allows them to
speak for themselves is still
something good and a step in the
right direction. In November of
2020, I decided to introduce
another way for people to
participate, which I've called
the Appalachian talkback series.
Basically, what I do is every
Monday, I post a question on
social media. And you can see an
example here on the left, that I
would then ask people to answer
in the comments. And I've
covered a lot of different
topics in the series, like media
representation, and the effects
of stereotypes. So things like
feeling pressured to code
switch. And I would say that
this, this series has actually
been one of the more successful
things that I've done in the
project, because more people
tend to participate because the
barrier to entry is much lower,
because you're just commenting
on a post rather than making a
whole submission. And it's also
much more pointed toward
creating counter neck counter
narratives and speaking directly
to stereotypes, rather than just
hoping that people might sit
submit that sort of content on
their own. I'd also like to
quickly talk about how I
approached co creation as a
member of the community in
Appalachia, I think the biggest
impact that being Appalachian
had on the way that I approached
this project is that it was a
huge influence on my decision to
be as flexible and as hands off
as possible in the type of
content that I received, both
through doing research for my
thesis, and also just growing up
noticing the way that Appalachia
was portrayed in media, I
realized that the vast majority
of popular media on Appalachia
is created by is created by
people who didn't grow up there,
who didn't really spend an
extended amount of time there
other than the time that it took
to make their news report their
film, and who really didn't seem
to understand the impact that
they were having on people that
live there. I also wasn't aware
of many opportunities for
Appalachian people to speak for
themselves in any sort of media,
no matter who had created it,
without heavy involvement on the
part of a director and editor.
So since COVID, had made it so I
would have to do this project
online. Anyway, I wanted to use
the affordances of the web to
give as many people a chance to
talk as possible. And I didn't
want to get in the way of what
they were saying. So that's
ultimately why I decided to open
up the project to any kind of
topic, even if it wasn't exactly
the kind of story that I was
most interested in. And it's
also why I only edited
submissions for spelling and
grammar. And I didn't make any
other major changes because I
really wanted each person to
retain their own voice and their
own agency and the way They
wanted to tell their story.
Also, being from Appalachia
allowed me to tap into pre
existing, pre existing networks
that I had, when it came to
things like borrowing equipment
to make videos, and finding the
people to participate in my
initial five videos, actually,
of the people who participated
have the five of them, I already
knew three of them personally.
The fourth was someone that my
mom suggested that I should talk
to. And the fifth was just
someone I kind of reached out
to, and they agreed to do it.
But I think having this network
already in place was really
helpful, both in getting people
to participate, but also in
already knowing a lot about
these people's stories. So I
think that helped me ask better
questions, and really get to the
heart of the issues that I
wanted to talk about. And
finally, being from Appalachia
was really helpful in growing my
audience. And I was also really
blown away by the response that
I got in the community, I mainly
promoted my work through social
media, and people were really
excited about this work, and
they were really willing to
share it. And they would also
suggest people that I should
reach out to and offer to help
in other ways. And I really
don't think that I would have
gotten this response if I had
been from somewhere else was and
was doing the same work. Because
there is definitely a distrust
of outsiders in Appalachia. So I
think people would have probably
been wary of what my real
intentions were. But on the flip
side, there's also a very strong
culture of support within
Appalachia. So there's this
sense that if one of us
succeeds, that we all succeed.
And I think that's also a big
reason that people supported the
project like they did, because
it felt like a win for all of
us. And now I'd like to move on
to some of the counter
narratives that have come out of
the project. The first one, I
think the most common narrative
is a celebration and a pride and
Appalachian culture, history and
people. This is counter to a lot
of popular media representations
that tend to portray Appalachia
as this place to be ashamed of
or a place that needs to be
escaped. But instead, people
will talk about their love and
their connection to Appalachia
and the people who lived there,
even if they did acknowledge
that it had problems. The second
counter narrative was
highlighting the diversity of
Appalachia, whether that's
racial and ethnic diversity,
religious diversity, or
highlighting the experiences of
women. This is counter to most
popular portrayals of the region
that show it as this completely
white male dominated and
Christian place. And the final
count counter narrative is a
direct speaking back or a
critique of Appalachian media
representation and stereotypes
in general. And a lot of people
actually went on beyond just
calling these stereotypes out,
and they would go on to talk
about the effects of stereotypes
in their own lives and in their
communities. So I'd like to
finish with just a couple of
conclusions from all of this.
The first is the importance of
thinking about director versus
participant control in
co-creative projects. And the
way that prioritizing one over
the other can affect the
outcome. I decided up front to
make the Appalachian retailing
project extremely purchase
participant driven. So my
strongest involvement was really
at the beginning in making the
first five videos and and
creating prompts and and
continuing to engage with people
on social media. But otherwise,
I tried to let people use this
project as a platform to say
whatever it is that they want to
say, and just for me to be the
person who promotes it. And I've
learned that this approach has
both affordances and drawbacks.
So some of the drawbacks are
that since this project is so
open ended, a lot of the content
that's on the website doesn't
necessarily achieve my goal of
creating counter narratives, at
least by itself. A lot of people
are just sending me like family
histories are finding stories.
And they're not thinking more
deeply about whether or not
they're trying to undermine
stereotypes of Appalachia. And I
think if I had been more
involved in the process of them
creating, I could have worked
more with them to make them
think about the topic in that
way. But on the other hand, I've
also received a lot of feedback
that giving people this platform
has been extremely empowering,
even for people who don't end up
submitting anything, just
knowing that this project
exists, and that they can
participate if they choose to,
and that I'm going to let them
share whatever feels important
to them. It really makes people
feel empowered. And I think that
is a positive result from this
project. So I think it's
important to consider if a goal
is the final narrative itself,
or if the goal is for the
process of creating to be
impactful. And that can kind of
help you decide the balance of
director versus participant.
And another thing that I've
realized through this work
that's kind of interesting, and
I hadn't really considered at
first was the importance of
being an insider versus outsider
when working in Appalachia. I
don't mean to say that someone
from outside Appalachia couldn't
make it so successful co
creative project in the region.
But I do think that being able
to say hey, I'm from Pikeville,
Kentucky, was really helpful in
getting people to trust that I
had good intentions. And people
were just really excited to
support another Appalachian who
was doing this work. I've also
realized that although I am from
the region, I think I inhabit
the sort of in Interesting
middle space between inside and
outside, because I grew up
there, and I still claim myself
as Appalachian. But I've also
spent pretty much all of my
adult life outside of the region
and with people who tend to know
very little about Appalachia
other than what they see in the
media. So I think as a media
maker, this positioning allowed
me to consider what I make both
from the perspective of an
insider and an outsider. And to
think about how the same content
might be read by these two
different groups. And having
that knowledge actually affected
a lot of the decisions that I
made throughout the project,
from the topics of the original
videos, to even things as small
as like the tone and the style
of the website. So while I don't
think that occupying this space
is necessary to work with a
group, I do think it was really
helpful for me. And I think that
it allowed me to come at this
project from a sort of unique
angle. And that's all I've got
happy to take questions.
Unknown: Right.
Vivek Bald: Let's open it to
questions. William.
William Uricchio: So Elon,
thanks very much. It's wonderful
to see how this project has has
continued to grow. And I guess
what I want to ask you about is
a lot of your a lot of your
discussion a lot of your framing
was really about, about counter
narratives about about the
expressive side people making
texts that that helped to
complicate the vision. But it
strikes me that that and that's
a that's a worthy and fine goal.
But these acts are also in a way
catalysts for a bigger
discussion. And are there
discussions coming out of this?
Is there a way you're able to
track that? In other words,
there's the media artifact, and
then there's kind of what goes
into it, which is hard to know,
if you're not, as you said, with
COVID, and everything, it's hard
to be there to be part of it.
But there's also that what comes
after it, is there, is there a
space for discussion? Is there a
dialogic side to this where,
where these are, these are, you
know, elements in like a
catalyst for for, for people
thinking and talking? And, yeah,
that's the question.
Elon Justice: Yeah. Um, so since
this project is so social media
Reliant in some ways, it's
actually kind of been one of the
cool things about it is that I
have been able to see a lot of
the discussion that's been
generated from my project. So
I'll see people share it on
Facebook or you know, on
Twitter, or whatever. And they
will actually it kind of add to
the conversation in some way.
And they'll, you know, they
might post about like experience
they've had in their own life
stereotypes, they might talk
about why we really do need to
think about, like, how we're
represented, and try and change
that. So I have seen some
discussions happening about
that. After viewing my work, I
feel like there was more to your
question.
William Uricchio: No, it's
really, it's really just in your
conceptualization of it, that
platform enables and for sure,
but it strikes me that, that
using these as ways to sort of
crystallize and provoke
discussion is that's where
that's where change often
happens. And I'm just wondering
if you know, social media is one
way to capture that. I know you
started with a website. Not sure
if that, you know, are there you
talked about partnering any
organizations you're working
with that might not like
platforms, like newspapers, or
churches or community groups or
anything like that?
Elon Justice: Yeah, yeah. So um,
throughout the month of March,
actually, I partnered with a
news organization based out of
West Virginia, called 100 Days
in Appalachia, and they have a
monthly newsletter series that
people will sign up for, and
they'll get the weekly
newsletter in their inbox. So I
took over their march
newsletter. And I really use
that to share mainly what I
talked about in the first
chapter of my thesis. So I break
down like the four different
stereotypes each week. And then,
in addition to that, I would try
and get I would like, share some
of the posts that I had gotten
on my website that kind of fit
into maybe a counter narrative
for each particular trope. And
then finally, I would like post
a series of prompts at the
bottom and tried to get people
to submit more content to my
project. But I think partnering
with 100 days was really great.
I thought it was I enjoyed it a
lot. And I got a big response
from it. Surprisingly, people
would actually just reach out to
me and they would like, try to
put me in contact with other
like I was put in contact with
like other journalists who were
kind of interested in this
topic. I was put in contact with
like academics who are doing
work in this space. So yeah, I
think it's been great.
Kenneth Manning: I don't know
why I want to tell times
can you hear me
Elon Justice: You're echoing
Kenneth Manning: I don't know
what to do. So
But anyway,
Elon Justice: you can post it in
the chat maybe and I can read
it.
Kenneth Manning: It meets your
needs.
Elon Justice: Maybe I can answer
Scot,
Kenneth Manning: can you hear me
now?
Unknown: Oh, no,
Kenneth Manning: no, no echo.
Elon Justice: You're good.
William Uricchio: One of you
left, Ken. One of you left. The
other one is still here.
Kenneth Manning: Thank you.
Thank you. Quite a wonderful
subject. I mean, I'm just
excited because it really goes
to the heart of my time to
thinking. First of all, I have
so many questions. Firstly, I
want to know, what did the WPA
do? are in this area? I mean,
have you looked at the earlier
work of the WPA, around similar
sorts of issues?
Elon Justice: Yeah, um, so I do
remember reading a little bit
about like, the PVA I don't
know, if you're kind of thinking
like the same thing? Yeah,
honestly,
Unknown: I mean, culturally, I
mean, I mean, you know, for
example, in the black community,
you have people making
recordings of, you know, of
stories and so forth. And I
think there were similar sorts
of projects as part of the WPA
in the 30s. Now, and that would
be a good sort of connection as
well. Yeah. But I think you
know, you know, I look at
programs like The Waltons, and
I'm, you know, I'm very
interested in the way this
country has chosen to portray
poor whites in general. But
especially in Appalachian
certain parts of the Carolinas,
and so forth, and so on. And all
of the social and political
implications, you know, behind
that, and how, you know, your,
your, your, your attention on
sort of the black community in
Appalachia is very important,
because there is one there,
people don't want to talk about
it. Um, and it's just such an
exciting topic, and you're doing
the right thing in getting the
stories that these people out
because they will be lost, if we
don't get. But more importantly,
I'm interested now, in the whole
issue of infrastructure,
embodied broadband. I mean, I
mean, what you're doing, really
does raise the question of, you
know, what is the internet going
to be like in these various
communities that are not
connected? If If there isn't
some kind of attention to
bringing, you know, broadband
throughout all of these rural
communities and so forth? Have
you thought about things like
that as well?
Elon Justice: Yeah, and I kind
of, it's interesting, when you
see it all kind of laid out,
because I actually do write
about it a little bit more in my
pieces. But it's interesting to
see how these kinds of things
like build upon one another. So
I learned that when the national
highway system was built, it was
actually they were instructed to
avoid mountains. So that
essentially cuts off Appalachia
from the rest of the country
that has now become much more
interconnected. And so when
people can't get in and out of
the region, you can't export,
you can't really connect with
other economies you can't grow.
And so I think, I mean, things
like that, are the reason that
we don't have broadband. I think
that they all kind of compile.
Unknown: Yeah, to me, and then
you you right now you have the
political situation with Joe
Manchin, really being the, you
know, the most important, so
called democrat right now, you
know, sort of representing West
Virginia, which is, you know,
totally Republican, and how bad
how people have, you know, sort
of pray these things against
each other. And this country
has, has traditionally, you
know, used achalasia and other
poor black communities in the
most insidious ways, and promote
its own racism, trying to turn
them as being racist when in
fact Racism is not from them.
But it's from the outside and
the kinds of things that you
just said. So, I hope that in
these projects, people will
begin to see how they have been
used by the, you know, by the
white power structure to promote
racial animosity at this very
low level. And it happens not
only in Appalachia, but in, you
know, and poor communities in
the south and other places as
well. But anyway, hi, I really
applaud you for your work.
Elon Justice: Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Vivek Bald: Um, Scot, you had
your hand up a moment ago, and
Scot Osterweil: I'd be happy to
wonderful work, I'm in a really
spectacular and clearly, there
are so many places in which
groups are other by media, you
know, by media, and the powers
that the power and power
structures. Have you thought
about deriving sort of
principles that would be
applicable, sort of, for other
communities, other groups to
also sort of change the
representation?
Elon Justice: You mean, and so
like, and creating new
narratives? You mean? Yeah.
Okay. Um, yeah. So I mean, I
think I maybe focus on it, or I
talk about it a little more in
my thesis. But since I am
drawing upon Stuart Hall, that's
kind of the way that I think
about it. But he talks about how
this there are kind of three
potential routes, you could go
about trying to create a new
narrative of somebody. So one
way is that you replace the
stereotype with its inverse. So
say that the stereotype is that
Appalachia is poor, you just
make a bunch of media about
Appalachians that are wealthy.
The next is that you try to
reverse the stereotypes, or
reverse the negative into a
positive. So you're saying that
the thing that most people say
it's bad is good. So people say
Appalachia is bad, we say
Appalachia is good. The third is
this idea of going inside the
image and actually trying to
contest these various
stereotypes from within. So I
think one great example that I
talked about a lot in my thesis,
it's a whole chapter in my
thesis that I didn't get to talk
about today is the film hollow
by Alain mcmillion. Sheldon, and
it's focused on a county of
people in West Virginia. And
they it's all about, like, what
is home to you, and how can you
save your home with it's kind of
dying, but they talk a lot about
how they feel that they've been
stereotyped as being like the
poor is the poorest county in
America as having a horrible
drug issue, and that, you know,
everyone that lives there is
like, hooked on pills and things
like that. And it's so
interesting to see that, like,
they don't avoid these topics.
They don't say, No, this isn't
happening. They don't say no,
we're the best. We're like,
Appalachia is the greatest place
to live in the world. They
acknowledge these problems. And
they say that they love it
anyway, that that's their home
anyway, and that it matters. So
I think that that is the most
effective way of going about
trying to contest dominant
representations is to not ignore
when these things are based in
truth. But to say that even if
they are we matter anyway.
Thanks.
Vivek Bald: Alright, Kat.
Kat Cizek: Thank you, Elon,
congratulations. And thank you
so much for inviting me into
your process and music as well.
It's been such an honor to
witness your journey from the
days that we met in Kentucky. To
this is wonderful. And I see the
mountain behind you there. And I
just wanted to point out, really
one of my favorite quotes in in
your work is about the
mountains, how there's the one
mountain of the dominant
narrative and the other mountain
of the counter narrative. And
then there's this space in
between. And I guess that's
that's what I that's the
question I pose to you is, and
you've opened up this space to
actually talk about these sort
of negative positive binary
situations, direct or
participatory, you've set those
out and laid them out clearly
and offered people a chance to
talk about that. And that's a
really important part of the
process. The next part is it's a
common response. So what is the
response for you as a director?
How, how are you going to move
forward in continuing to open up
that space into a third space
and use space between those two
very locked binaries?
Elon Justice: Yeah, um, so
that's something I've kind of
been thinking a lot about
lately, especially just in
regards to the project is like
what is next? Because I feel
like now could be a fitting time
to end it, but I also feel like
there's a lot more that could be
done in this space. So I think
personally, what I would do with
the project is I would love to
start actually working more with
people on how to think about
their stories. I think that I
got some great stuff just by
being very open about it. And I
think I would still allow that.
But I would love to, like, just
get to learn more about like
what people are doing and what
people are talking about, and
just reach out to them and say,
Hey, would you like to work with
me? And we can think about how
to tell the story together? I
think that, you know, it's like,
we've talked about how like,
it's not really a binary between
participant control and director
control. It's really a spectrum.
And you need to think about
where you fit on that spectrum.
And what's the most beneficial
spot to be? And so I think
that's, that's kind of what I'm
figuring out right now is where
should I be on the spectrum? How
much should I work with people?
How much should I give them
space to say what they want to
say?
Unknown: So yeah.
Vivek Bald: There's one question
actually quite, quite related to
this in the in the q&a. And that
is from Joshua Glick. And that
is fascinating presentation. I
love all the collaborative
dimensions of the project. Are
you thinking of synthesizing
some of the research and aspects
of the larger project into a
long form documentary? Or are
you leaning towards the
co-creative process continuing
to co creative process?
Elon Justice: I think I lean
more toward the co-creative
process. I think that making
long form films has just never
been my area of interest. For
one, I have a very short
attention span. I think that's
why I gravitate toward short
form content. But I also think
that it's just like, I don't
want this to be some final, like
art. Like thing. I can't think
of the word. I don't want it to
be some final things that just
never changes. I feel like this
is something that can keep going
on. And that can keep expanding.
So I think that's what I'm
thinking about.
Vivek Bald: All right. Thanks so
much, Elon.